[Music]
foreign
in the desert and suddenly you see this
Forest of columns coming out very high
to the sky
and next to it this Village of town
which was created for the occasion of
tents and that was already a fairy tale
story
it was a perfect setup for James Bond
plot it was so extravagant
it was so exclusive
it was the budget from Switzerland for
two years which they spent in two days
it was big big Executives everywhere yes
machine gun on every corner when you
have all the head of States I mean yeah
so much responsibility
historically and politically it's the
only time where everyone met you had the
East the West the Deborah countries the
underdeveloped countries the communist
countries the monarchies everyone was
there
the party is a bit like a debutant's
ball you know it's basically a coming
out
Iran is coming
you know the idea was I think that oh
you know we want to join the top tier of
nations with a bang
but it was the wrong Bank
if you spend the hundreds of million
you have to answer to somebody
[Music]
one day you pay
we may be sitting in on a television
first this morning the heads of state
are about to arrive in persepolis Iran
to help celebrate the 2500th anniversary
of the founding of the what was once
called the Persian Empire where we have
Barbara Walters Barbara there's so much
that one should understand about this
event both historically and and in terms
of modern times and I thought I'd try to
give you the who what where how and why
right now who well our host is the
Imperial Majesty
which means king of kings
it's been the shore since 1941. he's one
of the richest men in the world this
country is a constitutional monarchy the
shore has full power he appoints the
Prime Minister he can dissolve the
parliament he controls the Army he can
declare a war he can conclude peace
treaties he controls the Press very
little criticism of him is alive his
word is indeed the law
I have this firm belief that I have a
mission to accomplish
and I believe in God this is why I say I
think that I have a Divine command of
doing what I'm doing
[Music]
and this in addition to the special
relationship between the Persian people
and their King
that makes it a very special
relationship that maybe some other
people could not understand
thank you
[Music]
foreign
for the first time we see the new Shah
arriving at Parliament House to take
over the reins of office in succession
to his abdicated father shapua Mohammed
Riza and the former Crown Prince now
occupies the Peacock Throne the new Shah
has had to provide evidence that he'll
display a less pro-german attitude than
his deposed predecessor the ex shower
Persia exploited his people until his
own coffers were filled to overflowing
the new Shah has no easy task ahead of
him Iran is likely to remain much in the
news
[Music]
foreign
four Junior princes three vice
presidents including Vice President
Agnew four Prime Ministers seven sheets
and one wife of a president and that's
everything but a partridge in a pear
tree
foreign
[Music]
received foreign
foreign
[Music]
intellectuals had been arguing since the
late 19th century that the reason for
colonialism the reason for Iran's
weakness is Islam when Shah's father and
his ministers took over most of them
were educated in Western institutions
they're very adamant about modernity
westernization as well as going back to
ancient Roots so culture or cultural
Revival was part of a larger agenda of
secularizing Iran foreign
[Music]
was very conscious of his father's
Legacy but also I think he wanted to
distinguish himself from his father in
the sense that
I can do this better
[Music]
I never saw him in Exile I was
exchanging letters
he will never try to really tell me what
to do
only one recommendation
don't be afraid of anything ever
that is not possible I mean physically I
am not afraid of anything ever
death doesn't mean anything for me I
have seen it so many times right in
front of my myself in my eyes
and I know that today will come when the
day comes nothing will stop it
but mentally
constantly or afraid of something
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
attention is focused once again on the
Middle East where events in Iran have
taken a dramatic double twist forced to
free his Palace in Tehran the Shah and
his Queen arrive in Rome after an
alleged attempt by the Imperial Guard to
arrest Dr Masonic and a refusal by the
Shah to dissolve parliament at
musadich's request
I had not abandoned hope
my heart was light
it took only two days before the people
called me back
[Music]
um
until 53
my life was a succession of
pain
and suffering and humiliation
so he comes back in 1953 knowing very
well that this was a foreign engineered
coup d'etat in his name
um knowing very well that you know he is
coming into a country that essentially
does not want him
so what does he have to do as a
politician there are two ways one way
would be trying again to be the people's
Monarch within again the context that
was still in flux there's a lot of
radicalism a lot of disenchantment right
or
ruling with a strong hand and the Shah
with increasing funds through the oil
revenues with the increasing confidence
in his alliance with the United States
He established a militarized Security
State trying to find out how I can keep
myself in office as a monarch
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
was very efficient I think it was his
character to get it done he found the
simplest way to do it to go to a
professional
to do the tents to do the food to do the
catering the servants
[Music]
[Applause]
to myself
Boston
Virginia
foreign
[Music]
he's definitely in the Bible the Greeks
love him
um the Persians clearly valued him a lot
I mean he's one of the few that has a
two matches you know it's the one tomb
that nobody's demolished at any time
he's a figure that all political
factions in a way also can buy into he's
a humanist he's an Enlightenment leader
he emancipated he liberated the Jews he
likes minorities and he treated people
with dignity and Cyrus becomes this
Blank Slate onto which the Shah projects
his own image so that he may be
reflected in his glory
he was the first to introduce Justice he
was the first man who introduced The
Bill of Rights
we have the scroll
well you have the real scroll in your
Museum you take it from us
you know
hello
[Music]
system yeah
I think the problem of the white
Revolution was in many ways a top-down
process that was primarily I think
geared towards positioning the Shah as
that benevolent Monarch who gives out
charity almost to Iranians so it was in
many ways an act of propaganda more than
anything else
foreign
if you're unhappy that your country is
saying goodbye to a feudalistic system
if you are unhappy that half of the
population of your country the women are
emancipated
well this I cannot help
[Music]
Khomeini was a pure cleric his
grandfather his father all of them were
Steve in Islamic Theology and this whole
idea that Iran was not primarily an
Islamic country was for him utterly
unacceptable
foreign
the Jannah
I had to
Ascend one of those stubborn
obscurantist clergyman
abroad
he had to travel
[Music]
in England
through the government
foreign
[Music]
this is the Story of My Life
mystical and religious
but I believe the true religion
the religion of God the religion of our
Prophets
and not what has been added to it by
those who want to make it a
a job a profiteering job for themselves
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
was Associated to Perfection and
Iranians really did did like the show
they they've Associated themselves at
least when I was young and to to the
shore to the to the country having a
shop the shock was part of or everyday
life
[Music]
The Greatest Show on Earth is also going
to be one of the most select the Shahs
invited 60 of the world's heads of state
from as far away as Norway and Nepal
Lesotho and Liechtenstein to spend three
days with him in this special Royal
Village there's even a British
delegation
when Princess Anne and the Duke arrive
here at the setlist for the three-day
party they'll be accommodated like all
the rest of the 60 heads of state in a
tent in fact we're told in this tent
although protocol might change their
minds and switch everybody around
now this is the sort of thing they'll
have in each of these tents there are
six cut glasses on a tortoise shell tray
there's this perfumed candle in a glass
cylinder with a decorative snake
and an ornamental Iranian ashtray
for morning tea all Princess Anne will
have to do is give a little tinkle on
her bedside Bell for near at hand is her
personal maid who sleeps on a felt away
bed in the kitchen it's fully equipped
as are all the arrangements the tents
are all Tastefully situated in a forest
of young trees fifteen thousand of them
flown in specially from Versailles not
to mention the 15 000 flowering shrubs
and then in the top secret banqueting
tent is the food four tons of it again
all from Paris there's even a French
built Royal Club
is
responsibility
uh foreign
foreign
[Music]
each other
it worked eight seasons at The Palace
Hotel in San Moritz in the palace they
called me after the season they called
me of the city of Iran is making a big
party so we are all going to perfect
police
we were about 40 50 people from the
palace
I took the train from my home Valley and
I brought myself a sweet sausage and a
piece of bread my friends they already
went to Tehran before and they went to
the Hilton Hotel and had some caviar and
champagne
as we go to the play
everybody was quiet because a lot of
them
were afraid to fly
the most of them never have been in a
plane
will dance
[Music]
fullness
the Scandinavian monarchs had hide a
plane for the three of them and I went
into that thing with my Greek cousin
King Constantine and in the plane I
remember that I was discussing the
jewels that the Queens in the plane were
bringing Queen Anne-Marie said I'm
bringing the emeralds which are huge I
mean they were Romanov emeralds and
everyone was being the best I said
listen compared to what Empress Farah is
going to show is peanuts because she has
the most important jewels on Earth
at the beginning I thought it was just
bling bling and
as they say in Germany shikimiki that is
a little bit smart and it's not but
nothing interesting so then I changed my
mind
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
s from Spain there were not enough water
around for all the birds
but it wasn't suddenly
and was nothing good no very nice but he
did he wanted to make it look like a
forest I don't know why he bring all
these trees to the desert
is
I never do many imagine
[Music]
for days and days a week and airplane
full of ice was delivered a big block of
ice and put in a desert big like a
garage you know like a carport
I have a block of ice delivered every
day and we all go to the desert to cool
us down on these eyes but nobody I
didn't only the last day I realized that
this ice has to be chopped into pieces
for the ice buckets for the white wine
foreign
must have read about it but it just
seemed like
since I was a party reporter that's what
I was hired to do but this was going to
be the ultimate party and that I should
be there
[Music]
I stayed in Tehran for several days one
of the interesting things that happened
was and I later wrote about this in my
stories was how unhappy so many people
were about the celebration and what kind
of criticism they were getting for
spending all of this money when they
didn't have enough money to send
children to school or to feed children
and when I was there I met with them and
they said we're going to take you to a
meeting an underground meeting but we
have to blindfold you to take you there
I was in this room and there were these
they were all men
and they were very angry at the Shaw and
they basically said you know this is a
trumped-up Empire
the guy's father was a peasant he's not
an emperor and then they're spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on this
Festival which we can't afford in this
country
[Music]
James Mason
televisions
Cyrus King of Kings
Champion long before Magna Carta of
Human Rights and liberties
Cyrus the founder of Persian culture and
the father of Iran the land five times
the size of Great Britain
which this Shah rules today
it had fallen to him after a twilight in
his nation's long history
to remind the world and his own people
of Persian Pride
yes out of this world I have a shiver
going down my spine
it was remarkable
when when they saw this is silent and he
said
sleep well
we are alert
not be during
what was extraordinary did that was
speaking suddenly on both sides of the
Tomb
leave
the best though in spiral of dust
he repeats and it goes again up so
it was
an extraordinary
and I said
and how did they accomplish that I
thought that was prepared
it was like a
like a play both of you it was like
of Opera are the state
and I was
I was moved
but Osiris great king
of Kings hakamanian King King of the
land of Iran I the Iran offer these
salutations from myself and from my
nation
at this glorious moment in the history
of Iran I and all Iranians The Offspring
of the Empire which thou founded
2500 years ago power our heads in
reverence before thy too
[Music]
it's joking
again
foreign
[Music]
the last day before everything started
Mr Alam came and asked all of us to come
into the big hole and he said listen
from tomorrow you are on your own if you
get into trouble you have to improvise
and solve your problem on your own
think you are in war
I still
get
an excited Goose pimples when I remember
this verse
foreign
[Music]
in the middle of October 1971 62 heads
of state converged on the airport of the
fairy tale city of Shiraz
in a patchwork of color in a whirl of
salus boughs and curses familiar faces
in the world scene stepped out of their
aircraft over red carpets fringed with
gods of Honor into the welcoming Persian
sunlight
it was just like this
too much was happening to pick out the
detail
for all the arrivals ceremony and
protocol had to be carefully observed
none who were there so at all
so began one of the most historic
cultural gatherings the world has ever
seen
the only person that was sitting in
headquarters in precipitous was me
I couldn't sleep I was scared to death
because something this elaborate any
small things that could happen would be
a scandal one of these African countries
requested through our Embassy
that they would like to bring 10 people
with the head of state five was the
maximum
he said
either his personal guards
that two of them must sleep under his
bed
she said okay let this one
harvesting
and he brought 10 guys
Lasik came
with 75 people on a plane
I remember I went
nuts because these guys who's going to
take care of it 85 people
[Music]
foreign
you've never seen a tent like this
before it's not like your average
camping tent they were like little homes
I mean they were gorgeous and everything
looked like it had come right out of a
decorating magazine you could pull up
your chair and sit outside your tent so
some of the kings and queens were kind
of sitting outside their Tantra some had
the tents open you know the sort of
Prince Philip waving it you know the
king of Denmark and somebody else waving
and then Grace Kelly and Prince Rainier
and everybody said Hi how are you good
to see you they'd stop and chat it was
I have never seen anything like it and
there's never been anything like it
since everything was done with the most
Exquisite taste and it was not at all
nuvoice not at all gold everywhere or
not but it was good taste city is
[Laughter]
[Music]
you couldn't walk three steps without
falling over some security guard
the king of Denmark was trying to get
through to something and they threw him
out and only later did they find out
that he was the king of Denmark
it was very tight very tight
um
[Music]
in 1971 there was more and more gorilla
Warfare and not only anyone but
elsewhere as well the Vietnam
counterculture the revolutions happening
in Cuba are seeing Che Guevara these
people were not reformers they were not
Bourgeois middle class you know people
who were worried about their mortgage
they were worried about changing
their countries but also world history
foreign
among many critics in the West Was seen
as essentially a tin pot dictator not a
liberal man at all
do the punch by the shower panjuries
some of them were fairly felt a bit
awkward about the pretensions the child
was betraying clearly in in Britain for
instance they were not keen for the
queen to go because they thought if he's
pushing it about that he's the premier
Monarch in the world or this you know we
don't want to be in a position where our
monarchs
are seen as subscene a Peng Peng homage
to the King of Kings
foreign
[Music]
should not be spending millions of
dollars on this celebration while there
are still people in need how do you
answer these critics and why do you
think it was important to have this
celebration
uh first of all how do they know about
what is spent really the the only
expenses that are made for the
festivities are the two official dinners
that we are going to give our guests
this is the least that we could do for
such a gathering
[Music]
everybody arrived at the entrance of
that big tent at eight o'clock
it was more than surreal it was
unbelievable it was the biggest event of
my life
to see all these people it was so little
place for example they hadn't invited
all the ministers
the cabinet was not there
many Iranians were even Iranians were
not invited there was no room
they
simply no room
foreign
people hadn't planned exactly what they
were going to do with all these monarchs
I mean they had them in their tent
cities but then what
nobody had really thought what was going
to happen once they all came in that
huge tent and so the Shaw and the
shabanu were there to greet them the
guests and they started piling up
because they couldn't get through the
receiving line quickly
the problem is that not everybody
arrived on time and not everybody went
in within two or three minutes so after
some time there was a queue according to
the rules of protocol Kings take
precedent against others due to their
permanence so they had to go in first
there were too many of them and more
were coming so there were two queues one
of kings and queens and one of lesser
Mortals like presidents and prime
ministers it was just unbelievable and
then there was this huge dust storm that
came up and that was trying to and
people's hairdos were getting undone and
the crowns were being held on so they
wouldn't blow off and the dresses were
swirling and the dust was getting
people's eyes and and they were trying
to push their way in so they wouldn't
have to stand out in the dust storm
foreign
just came up the wrong time I was scared
that this beach chandelier will fall on
somebody's head you know the people it
was like the end of the world this was
not exactly what he expected for opening
up the party
finally everyone
every billionaire and David
Ians were related to each other but a
lot of people didn't know each other
there wasn't anybody there to sort of
say oh you know the the emperor of Japan
I want you to meet that's highly Celeste
you know so these people will sort of
stand off in corners and stare at each
other
how are the Royals and the Communists uh
the best
the best the best communist Androids
went on to Perfection as it very often
happens
even if the Russians had murdered I
don't know how many Royals but that was
all in the old days
[Music]
where the Headway to fainted before the
party and we had to carry illness some
medicine to calm him down five people
had to hold him we had to put him to the
medical there was a medical tent and we
had to give him tranquilizers until he
has couldn't take it the pressure he
just kept five people had to hold him
because he didn't know what he was doing
anymore and it was a tremendous place
you know you have all the head of states
and then the food is not properly ready
so that's not exactly what you are
looking for as a head waiter but I don't
think the customer realized it because
they had so much to talk together when
they arrived and the weather it's half
an hour later or not passing they had
enough time to talk together I don't
think the customers realized that we
were in panic
and it was very hot in the kitchen area
so the the people in the kitchen area
were practically nude but taking off
most of their clothes and a lot of them
were the men were sort of in these
bikini underwear
this was the big book where the menu is
inside
so this is a very a very nice glass that
we could show to see where you was
so with the first blade was perfect
everything the best thousand kilo caviar
the scavier you know is not bread
it was caviar at the big dinner but no
they were not Night and Day Care yeah no
protocol was a nightmare of all
nightmares at this thing everybody was
sort of looking to see where everybody
else was seated and who had a better
seat and who had a better ranking so all
that was going on at the same time
it was very interesting to watch all
this Intrigue
three people used to sell one devil is
one control the other
away from the Army checking that we
don't put any poison in the food or
something
the universities
[Music]
the second plate was a moose sauce
foreign
[Music]
to tell you the truth me personally I
almost didn't eat anything I was only
looking around looking at people
[Music]
the table cloth was hundreds and
something meters long in one piece
is
oh
no no no no no
no this is foreign
[Music]
the sound and light show was I remember
that it was very cold and very windy and
everybody was really tired and would
rather have gone back to their tent
instead of bundling up and going up to
the top of the hill to watch a sound and
light show
open the gates guarded by winged bulls
with human heads
ET
the Hamilton
it was three minutes three minutes is a
long time
foreign
in San Francisco there was an explosion
in the Iranian consulate during the
night that set fires throughout the
three-story Stone building there was
Heavy damage but no one was injured
numbers of Iranians around the country
had protested the Shah of Iran's lavish
celebration of the 2500th anniversary of
his dynasty a celebration on which we'll
have live coverage by satellite later in
this half hour
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
ly on our feet
and by the grace of God we are going to
progress
and with or without the sympathy of the
outside countries or people we shall
enter the era of the great civilization
we shall regain our past prestige
and I hope that you will know that I'm
not speaking
in a spirit of vanity
I am full of humility but I am very sure
of my people
and very sure of our destiny
[Music]
the great civilization was the world
which was repeated many many times in
every speech and in every headline of
the newspaper
it was to give us a sense of Pride and
to help us go ahead with the
modernization of Iran and to be sure of
ourselves as Iranians
[Music]
foreign
what I can say is that we are now
sophisticated enough
to use the same methods that you people
are using
for interrogating
the people that you have to
who are you referring to says any any of
the
sophisticated societies they have some
very efficient system of interrogation
which is much more psychological Than
Physical we do the same things as you're
doing
and do you regard that as Justified
it depends on what cases in case of
betrayal of one's country
I could say anything goes
foreign
you can hear stories
that even in police prisons
police officer or Detective
gets so mad at the behavior of the
fellow that he has just arrested
that he loses all his head and he just
punches on that fellow or
breaks a chair on his head
these are some kind of human reactions
that it's almost beyond control
foreign
[Music]
what is it that uh makes an Iranian what
is the quality that binds the tribes
when a thousand miles away from here
with the person giving a party in in
Tehran what what is the common bond that
links them all
I'm not not making any propaganda but I
think it's the crown the king
that it's you
at this moment yes
of the celebrations
the first glimpse of the flood-lit
monument outside the airport of Tehran
in honor of the present Shah
that Monument is a moment sort of an
iconic imagery that for them speaks
about the good life and I think what is
so tragic about that is that that good
life is always in the past
when the prince left
alarm asked me over and said
take care of the tents
I went
to each one
and made a list
of what's inside
many of the things that were inside were
gone already
they're taking it
now we're taking the heads today I have
no idea I don't wanna accused of those
things for seeking a telephone can radio
because we ordered 50 of them for each
tent
but I
when I encountered there was only one
left
so maybe those who were working there
took them
Allah
um
[Music]
foreign
I think it's a very high caliber the
person come to say
is
foreign
yes it's a very very special
case if I can't say so
in what way is it special I mean to be
as you say the the king of kings
and it means that you're lonely because
you really have
no one to go to for advice who's above
you well there's always God
foreign
he was not the only one that I could
blame I I blame myself my I know my
husband blames himself we've started
forgetting our own Traditions copying
other modern countries I remember that
until I was maybe 15 or 16
I used to pray
after that when I went to high school I
stopped praying and I forgot about
religion in a way I don't know I I blame
myself my claim myself because I didn't
realize that my cook was a Muslim and he
he prayed three times a day
and I would go in the in the
in the kitchen to tell him what to cook
in my bikini
and he would turn his back to me and
make believe that he was doing something
I didn't realize that he didn't want to
look at me I didn't realize he didn't
realize that the country was Muslim
[Music]
ited
foreign
[Music]